These first three values of f we want to rewrite can be rewritten using
exponents, 2 times 2 is just 2 squared. Three 2s, multiplied together, is 2 to
the 3rd, and 2 times 2 times 2 times 2 is 2 to the 4th power. We can see here
that the base of each of these exponential expressions is 2, and in each one,
the exponent corresponds to the value of x. The same should be true for these
three values of f down here. F of 10 should be 2 to the 10. F of 100 should be
2 to the 100, and f of x should just be two to the x. Now, maybe without even
realizing it, you've actually just found the equation for your first
exponential function. It's right here, f of x equals 2 to the x. So that you
can keep acquainting yourself with different exponential functions, I'm
actually going to give you a new one to check out right now.